[Music]
hi everyone my name is shade I'm a
product manager on Chrome OS thank you
very much for coming to the session
today I've had the chance to speak to a
few of you here really delighted that
you here with us
so today we're going to talk a little
bit about optimizing Android apps for
Chromebooks and large screen devices so
just before I start that it love to get
a show of hands who here has used chrome
OS before that's awesome
Hugh here has a Chrome OS device wisdom
right now and if you do have it could
you hold it up okay great all right
thank you so the chrome OS team are on a
live stream in the Googleplex and
they're watching all this so we're
always really excited to see folks using
Chrome OS we thank you for doing that so
for those of you who have been exposed
to Chrome OS before I've come across it
before and spoken to us before you're
probably very familiar with these three
ideas we've been very consistent about
the ideas behind Chrome OS since we
started we won't criminalize to be fast
faster startup class we use we want it
to be easy
won't it be easy to use it's a tool the
way that we think about it is we want
Chrome OS to get out of the way you can
get to where you want to go we don't
want to show pop-ups announcing a a
driver update selling your productivity
software you should just get to where
you want to go and security that's been
top of mind for us since chrome OS began
so that's led to some big moments for us
over the last few years so at i/o last
year we announced that Chromebooks
shipments overtook Macs in the United
States now that's in part due to our
strengthened etu where Chromebooks
outsell every other device combined but
that's also been the case in retail so
we've seen nearly 20 percent growth
year-on-year in holiday weeks of the 50%
growth so Chrome OS is really strong and
continues to grow but if we talk today
about optimization it's not just helpful
for Chrome OS so phones like the Samsung
Galaxy s8 where this desktop projection
mode user windowing system and a lot of
the optimizations we talked about today
will be helpful for that too
there's also devices that are in a
laptop format that run Android like the
Lenovo yoga book in the 8:12 they use
keyboard the touchpad input so thinking
about how to optimize the Chrome OS will
help to these form factors too so it's
look a little bit about desktop apps and
how they're they're different from the
mobile form factor so mobile apps to
myself I tend to use them in short
bursts maybe a few minutes maybe 20
minutes at a time and if I think about
buying a mobile app it's something it
could cost a few dollars desktop apps I
and maybe many of you use those for many
hours at a time during the day and
buying one of those buying that for a
few hundred dollars is not unreasonable
so these simple changes from the form
factor a bigger screen faster input with
mouse and keyboard drive a really
different kind of usage and the first
thing that we might think about as
Android developers is how do we extend
our current app onto the desktop
platform and then ongoing we may think
about other opportunities to do
something very different on the desktop
platform so that different type of usage
has been reflected in our own analytics
so we've seen that users who are using
immersive apps like messaging gaming
productivity spend more time on that app
in a Chromebook than they do on mobile
devices and so an example is AutoCAD so
it met a couple of developers back there
who will us today thanks for coming
they've been working with us to try and
optimize and some of the the usage that
we've seen on Chrome OS devices has been
much stronger so let's talk a little bit
about some of those a high level
specifics about what you can do to
optimize the Chrome OS and also these
large screen and other types of devices
first Chromebooks work like any other
Android device so if you have an app in
the Google Play Store it probably
already works on Chrome
while many developers test only for
mobile which is completely
understandable it's just seeing the app
for the first time running on Chrome OS
will probably illustrate the need to do
some optimization work those
optimizations usually come down to four
differences between mobile and desktop
the first is wider screams it's probably
the most common issue so of course your
mobile device has a screen that's this
wide your laptop device will have a
screen that's this white and some apps
don't use screen real estate maybe like
they should and that's not just
third-party apps this is work that we
have to do too so this is an example of
maps running in the Explorer around you
view on Chrome OS and you can see
there's a narrow strip of content in the
middle and the contents not reflow in
properly to take up gaps on the side of
the screen this is another example - the
conversation from Google Hangouts and as
you can see each message from each of
the participants it's hard aligned to
the left and right so it's hard to read
downwards the I have to jump from from
side to side to get there the gist of
the conversation
the second item phones a default
portrait laptops a default landscape so
this is an example this is scornful rise
of Balor and Android game Chrome OS
respects that setting that locks an app
to portrait so on a landscape screen the
screen is the view is still in portrait
so that leaves a lot of the screen blank
and if you can see here those rich
graphics are locked in a strip in the
center of the screen the third item is
win during so many apps assume that the
display size is equal to the window size
and that's not always the case even on
Android part of the value of desktop
though is multitasking being able to see
lots of different windows and apps
running at the same time so it's often
not the case that the window size of
equal to the display size apps need to
understand that so for example they can
correctly understand the input of a
stylus for example and draw the ink in
the correct position and there's no
offset errors
and finally keyboard pointer and stylus
input so there's lots of common states
here that are uncommon on mobile so for
example hover states that will show
things like tooltips I hover over an
icon tooltip appears it's just really
unusual to be able to do that on mobile
and the reverse is also true
so States and actions that are really
common on mobile could be less common on
desktop so an example swipe to dismiss
for example of an email or an item in a
list that's super easy to do and very
intuitive on mobile where you have touch
that's right there whereas on desktop
doing that with a mouse is it's a little
a little more unusual those kinds of
updates that we're talking about can be
very simple so let me give you an
example so we've been working closely
with the team at slack and so this is an
example of slack app running on Chrome
OS so those of you slack probably
familiar that and the bottom right here
there's a big box for entering your next
message and sending it out to the team
so if you type that in and press ENTER
originally that just sent a carriage
return I think if the mobile device
wasn't used to seeing keyboard input so
it wasn't tested very understandable but
the slack team helped us to do a little
work optimizing this and now hitting
Enter will send a message so it works
like you'd expect
so this is a quick summary of the top
level items that will help those apps
work like you'd expect on desktop and
get you happier users so with that I'd
like to introduce Stephan our tech lead
for window management on Chrome OS
hello everyone thank you all for coming
I'm here to talk about how to improve
your application for the use of the
desktop world means with Chromebooks or
large screen devices the most important
thing you can do to your application in
order to get best out of tehse the world
is go to at least API level 24 because
with API level 24 we can remove all the
restrictions or window sizes and whatnot
which we have export in place for all
the applications the next big thing you
should really do is you should you
should use both orientations so as we
have seen earlier so the thing is most
applications are coming nowadays in
phone size means like it's a its
portrait and the thing is quadrant alone
is yeah good for a phone but it's not
good for for for a desktop so therefore
by having also landscape at the same
time you are improving the usage of your
application on a desktop device the next
thing well if you ever have to only
really rely on one orientation which as
possible you can actually specify that
and please specifies it in the manifest
so that we know that this is the case
the next thing you should do is well
there are different sizes of screens you
might actually have something which is
10 inch but you might actually have
something with a 40 inch or maybe
something like that I don't know where
is that in the living room but it would
be nice right so and with that you
definitely want to show of course more
content and therefore by using the
standard mechanisms which already in
Android multiple layouts and whatnot you
can do all these kind of things yeah and
then there is mouse and keyboard
well mouse and keyboard is something
which is totally useful or a notebook
but on the phone you have possibly never
really used it with a good reason so the
next thing is you should actually add
stuff for for accessibility like for
example adding content descriptions so
that the user can actually hear what you
are doing there so and then they of
course all the usual suspects like for
example all these old API switch are
there already since ever like drag and
drop support
it's like the hover API which we have
heard earlier and all these kind of
things by doing so you are doing a
perfect job of getting into a good
desktop experience and you know or most
of these api's are already there they
have nothing really new and by doing
that you're also getting a much better
citizen on the phone world so with it
coming to the window management on
Chrome OS so we have learned some
lessons from our previous year so in our
previous year we had well our first
incarnation which was built on em and
yeah it has a lot of problems we said
the both beta and beta it was well there
are millions of applications there are
many different api's well back then it
were 24 now it's 26 and if you're going
online you're trying to search for
example on how to figure out what the
size of the screen is well you will get
70 different versions of how you can do
that or even more and the thing is
everything will be uploaded well that
tells you if something will go wrong
well can go wrong it will definitely go
wrong there's no question there so then
there were the problems of of
orientations like for example you're
starting an application SATs out
landscape then it change the support
rate and it jumps around and this is of
course totally annoying for the user and
we had some good good ideas in mind of
actually adding their special button
which allows you to change the
orientation at any point in time which
was which was well thought but the
problem is that since an application
could at any point in time say hey I
really want to be portrait suddenly the
button was disappearing it was gone so
which was of course also very confusing
to the user so then we had application
restarts so unexpected one so like for
example the window changes its eyes and
it lost the state and the user was then
had to actually restart the game from
the beginning which was of course
totally annoying all these kind of
things are pretty bad so and at the end
we had then of course a problem that the
windows they didn't really expect to be
in a window it was to begin with which
was another problem
which brings me to our next thing so
this are in our new window manager the
special window modes we are supporting
so essentially we have the pre density
aware applications these are always
being shown fullscreen so I really hope
that you are not programming any of
these kinds of applications anymore
unless you want to have the biggest
button of the world might be a good a
good thing but you possibly don't want
that so the next thing is free and free
and that is something in between that
means it includes marshmallow well we
figured out that most of the
applications out there they are working
fine so they are they're working
reasonably well but the thing is there
are a lot of applications which don't so
and with that we were getting a lot of
beta feedback and so on so and in order
to resolve this issue we have put them
all into Windows so they are static now
they have always the same size it's like
it's coming up in phone size so and it
can then be either landscape or portrait
the user has an option we can actually
then say hey I want to add that thing as
big as possible which makes it then a
portrait size window on a landscape
screen which is the biggest thing what
you can do and if it rotates it's not
filling the screen entirely but that is
free and if you are moving to n what I
told you already it's a good idea to do
you have then the full freedom of
getting resizable you can actually be
full screen you can be windowed and so
on and so on and if you don't want to be
resizable in ends you can say I want to
be unreliable which essentially puts you
in the full desktop and then the last
thing is you can actually have an
application which essentially dictates
us hey I want to be this size and at
this location and we respect that so the
big thing the big change to previous
versions was the via happy have a new
rule and that is that the root
activities rules which essentially means
that the root activities is the wealth
you have multiple activities which are
making up the task spec and the top
activity is the one which you see and
the bottom most one that is a root
activity so if the root activity is for
example let's say landscape and it's
resizable that
that every activity which goes on top is
also landscape and resizable it sounds a
little bit weird right because the thing
is that would mean that if you have an
application which was meant to be
portrait it and maybe Unruh size with it
could suddenly become resizable and
landscape which is a contradiction in
itself right well the thing is first if
you're looking on the phone and you have
two side by side mode the same thing is
being done there and the second thing is
that most of the applications which are
really locked into one mode again so in
the games they usually don't use layouts
and whatnot and therefore they really
need this treatment but once you're
using a layout and the standard
framework which gives you all this kind
of thing it can relay out your form your
stuff so that it's still usable that way
and with this you have no window jumping
everything looks much cleaner to the
user and it's really a good experience
so and so and then there is well you
have possibly seen already Chromebooks
right promotes looks like this but you
know if you have not seen it you can
also convert it into a tablet form
factor so what happens when you're going
into the tablet form factor in that case
we are we are actually forcing the size
if it's an M application for the size
will actually then be restricted to
whatever I bought before but the
orientation can go exactly as you are
doing it on a phone which means like the
route activity doesn't have any kind of
impact on that anymore so orientation I
mentioned that earlier already we have
well two orientations which was portrait
and landscape well one is good for
phones one is good for world satellites
and notebooks and then there's
unspecified unspecified means you can do
both we definitely encourage you to do
that because that's best so and if you
really have to use one of these things
please specify that in your manifest
file please put in that you have to be
landscape don't make us guess what you
might actually want or want not to
because we cannot guess that so
therefore if you want to avoid jumping
or any kind of weird scenario please put
that in there
so and then look at that
so if you are specifying your
orientation
you should definitely specify also sends
or because the problem is when I'm
playing a game or something or I'm using
Android and I'm going from this mode
into this mode which is very natural
right it's upside-down and the other
thing is the camera is here
see it's he is not they are like on a
phone so it doesn't even make much sense
to actually say hey I need to come round
top because it's not really on top of us
anyway
and the worst thing which can be done
that is going into the manifest files
specifying your landscape and then call
later on Fett requested orientation with
another orientation that is really
throwing off everything so please don't
ever do that
so launch sizes you have a various
possibilities to actually get a certain
window and a certain size so there are
first hints this is something new which
we have done especially for for our form
factor which means like desktop you can
spend especially give us some kind of
hints what you want to see inside a
desktop environment so do you want to
have a small window a big window those
should be landscapes or be portrait by
specifying these kind of things you
should actually be put into the right
size without worrying of which size
exactly it is then the next thing is you
can actually start your intent with a
special options command which is already
there since N and by specifying the set
launch bounds you can then move your
window to a certain size and location
and the last possibility you have is for
every intent you can also specify a
layout command which allows you to give
you a minimum size a default size and
where it should actually be laid out on
on the screen should be left right top
and so on so what kind of window modes
do we know well we know of course
windows as as we are running on a
desktop and in this case if you're
running in this mode you will actually
run in
think it's a 5 X sized screen on on that
screen so which is which SN portrait if
you are maximized you will actually see
the caption or the the application
control bar on top and the window will
always cover the entire screen so even
if you are only portrait the rest will
be blanked out just black and then if
you are in this mode your application
can then request to be full screen it
can actually do the standard stuff
widget which is also always common on on
Android to simply say I want to take
over the system UI I want to be full
screen and then we are going out of your
way and the caption and as well as the
shelf will be hidden yeah
the most important thing to get more
space being used properly is at more
layouts for bigger sizes so you can exit
well the thing is the more sizes you
have the better it is especially with
bigger sizes avoid restarting as well
there are some applications if you are
not using the layout system you should
try to to avoid the resizing and and do
the on layout change command yourself
because that way you can actually get a
smooth experience we come to that one
later however you should always use on
safe instance and on restore instance
because that is helping you on Android
world as well as on on the Chromebook
world as better the restore function is
as better as for the user the only thing
on a phone is you don't really notice it
that much but if you have a window and
suddenly the content is gone and you see
something else from the beginning that
is quite annoying so
and oh yeah if you are resizing the
window you should definitely make sure
that if there are some elements on the
screen which you cannot access and there
can be gone
don't try to access them you've seen
some applications pressing because of
that and that was of course not fixable
glass so here's a good example for a
large screen layout and you probably
know it and you have seen it since years
but it's always a good thing to show
again so there is a portrait application
well portrait shows you only one line
and you have then the landscape version
where you get simply another part of the
screen like that so which is something
which you have seen this fragment or a
since a long time so next thing is
Netflix users the whole screen
efficiently to display the title imagery
the knobs is an episode list to give you
the users contextual information before
eating play so one thing what I was
mentioning earlier is there is
unfortunately a caption or a window
control bar this thing is unfortunately
at least for now part of the window so
it is inside your view hierarchy if you
are now putting something into the root
of the view hierarchy you might actually
mess up something they are so for the
time being we should really encourage
you to not do this kind of thing and
according to the framework teams isn't
something what you shouldn't do it
anyways so therefore try to avoid that
if possible the next thing is you should
actually always make sure to not assume
that the top left corner of your window
is at 0 0 it's most certainly not
because they source the caption and then
comes your content so always try to get
your coordinates relative to the content
or region and if you have the window
size from your application you will
actually get the window size including
the caption so essentially that means
that your content is a little smaller
than the real full window when you're
resizing has a lot of hurdles
unfortunately so as I mentioned earlier
to make it seamless you should really
have the save and restore fun
gee and again this thing is something
which has to also in the Android world
this is not really only something for
Chromebooks you should have that anyways
either way so and and if you are using
on configuration change and you are
doing dynamic layouting please add that
there as well
if you don't want to be resized you can
actually put into your activity resize
word for word which is for the most part
true there are some edge cases where you
can get resized but usually this is true
and your window size will not be the
display size for sure
so therefore always use get activity get
resources get configuration screen width
and height in DP in order to figure out
what's the real size of your window is
oh yeah so then the next thing is to get
the current configuration of the screen
and the matrix and everything you should
use get resolves get configuration which
was more less responsive already so the
window bounds can change at any point in
time so be aware of this that you are
not really statically caching the size
of the screen or the window somewhere we
have seen that also in some applications
which are simply first time they run
they simply get then the size of the
screen they store it somewhere in their
own data and I never look at it again
they scale everything and thereafter
when you resize the window everything is
looking funny you don't really try to
avoid that as well so and then yeah if
you're using the layout system
everything will be done automatically
otherwise you have to take care of it
yourself
you can do that via OpenGL which is when
resizing pretty nicely but yeah so if
you have a native application you should
actually get the fat size looking at em
last content x5 rice width and height
you should actually or you could also
use your content and you should
definitely then listen to all the
changes which are coming down the pipe
VR
listeners so definitely look at any kind
of changes which can happen to the
layout and/or your window size so with
that let me show you a short a short
demonstration by Margaret sang about
resizing great thanks everyone my name
is Margaret and today I'll be showing
you some pretty cool things that your
Android app can do on Chrome OS actually
I have here one of the latest chrome box
with Samsung Chromebook pro that we'll
be releasing soon with a new git rebase
of Play Store on Chrome so let's get
started you can see that it's pretty
small on the screen right so from here
it's very hard to see I'm going to go
ahead and resize the app and again I
could typically do that by hitting this
little maximize button or the
full-screen key but I actually have a
developer option enabled that lets me
perform freeform resizing by dragging
the borders of the window so see that
the content scales really well and very
beautifully and the content also updates
dynamically so if you're able to do
something like this into your app you'll
be giving your users much more control
over their desktop real estate and with
that I'm going to send you back over to
sip on to talk about just how you can
enable these developer options so that
you can also try these on your apps to
suite
Thank You Margaret so to get to the
developer options all you have to do is
you have to go first into the chrome we
know you go into the settings and you
type in Android and then you will see
the highlighted Android section and you
click on Android settings a side tip
usually actually now go into yourself
right click on it and pin it to the
cells so that you can access it later on
quicker when you need to and with that
so there are currently two developer
options of interest for you the first
one is the dynamic resizing option so
you should definitely turn that on and
try to test your application sees that
it's actually first dynamically fluidly
resizing everything so if it's not
resizing fluidly what you should do is
you should actually look into your
activate so if it is not dynamically
doing that and you're using the layout
system and you are getting restarted you
should actually make sure that all the
resources which are which you are using
they are cached that you're not trying
to reallocate them again because that
takes time and that makes the whole
process much Legia and it doesn't look
that good so as you have seen just in
our demonstration it can be really
really smooth so therefore a smoother at
neither this and that the next thing is
well as I said earlier we have this kind
of route rule and you don't really know
exactly what your window is doing and if
you ever come to the point where you are
not really sure what you see you can
always turn on the second option with
this to show the content while the the
state of the window manager which is
then presented in the window title wise
you can see here for example there's an
resizable lu which means that it's the
state you means it can do both it's
currently in landscape and it's an N
resizable application which is the best
thing what can happen so in the second
or P no actually I was joking there's a
third option so there is another one if
you want to also test already maximize
you can actually turn on an option which
is named something like default size and
orientation yada yada yada and you put
that thing into use phone-sized window
and default to portrait orientation and
allow portrait only application to
maximize so if you select that thing you
can also maximize your portrait
applications which gives you them the
control bar everything as I said so we
have not turned that on yet by default
but it'll come soon or later so
therefore you can already go ahead and
try that as well so then if you are
using a camera you have most certainly
already seen something and our previous
experiments with with this M that was
you were starting an application and
suddenly everything was like somehow
rotated which was not really that great
so and for the question is how can you
fix these kind of things well the first
thing what we want to tell you is if you
are moving to at least N and you make
your window resize will we take care of
you
so with that we should be able to make
everything work for you but without that
unfortunately you might actually need
some edge cases which don't work so
therefore to be doing that will fix
everything
so from window manager to input related
topics well the thing is as I said
earlier phones are a little bit
different and I guess you're possibly
never used the keyboard with the mouse
with your phone right yes me neither so
the first thing which you should do is
there are input focus elements on your
screen so on the thing is at the moment
Android is trying to guess what you
might actually want to have there how
you are actually navigating through that
on a desktop do you expect a little bit
more than that so by using for example
tap key you want to accept to them you
have want to use directional keys and
this is something which is an Android
since ever however the thing is like it
was not really used that much because
the keyboard was not used so if you want
to use it you can tip the headset to
your manifest file s points out here as
pointed out I think API level I don't
know 12 something really pre all so
therefore simply go online and check it
out it's totally easy to do and it helps
a lot of people especially for
accessibility and so on so the next
thing is if you want to handle keyboard
actions you can use you can use key
event callback handler so this thing
will allow you to actually get all the
keyboard events directly and to do
something with us like for example in a
game you can also use them the modifiers
to check out if for some the shift key
was pressed or something and you can do
that special actions on that you don't
have to really reimplemented the
TextEdit feels that is always there but
if you ever want to add a text you
should actually use on key down on key
long press and on key up to do your text
detection please don't use on key pre
IME unless you really want to implement
the full I am e stuff you don't want to
do that please leave this to us and use
only the key Sun at handling
and off to Margaret for text input demo
thanks for fun okay
Adobe as a developer that has taken the
next step into implementing their
keyboard shortcuts into their Android
app which typically breaks the barrier
between your traditional mobile and
desktop users all right here I'm going
to go ahead and show you some shortcuts
that adobe has implemented into their
lightroom app here's a collection of
some photos that I already have in my
library and the first thing I want to do
is try to go through each photo and
raise them from 0 to 5 stars by pressing
on the corresponding keys numbers on the
keypad so let's get started
I remember this is amazing meal so three
a beautiful place beautiful picture so
five delicious meals at homemade so four
and so on and so far and you can see
here that I was also able to traverse
through the photos using the
navigational arrow keys alright so now
let's say I want to make a collection of
food photos I can easily do that by
pressing X to reject P to pay and if I
want to reverse this at any time I can
click you you can see how easy I was
able to go through and organize my photo
if you are able to also implement some
of these keyboard shortcuts into your
app you'll also be able to increase user
productivity workflow as well so with
that I'll hand it back to sip on to talk
more about how to utilize some other
hardware features like Mouse and salad
Thank You Margaret
so some of Chrome OS support now a
stylus as you have probably seen already
with our expeditions 12 desert a I can
find us oh it's not there great ok so if
you want if you don't care about any
kind of input related things like what
kind of device it is well you're done we
don't have to do anything because if
you're using already the motion event
that is all fine if you are on the other
hand interested in for example pen input
well then usually actually calls the
motion event get to type which gives you
exactly the kind of device here you
you can get the end the pressure and the
tills so however the thing is of course
you're getting one of these events only
per frame which means like you're
missing out on all the position what we
can give you so in order to get
everything you want to have the
presentation movement and for that you
should actually have an additional look
and to get historical XY and pressure
and excess value which gives you then
the full path so that the other thing
what we have is a very sophisticated
palm rejection which means like even
though when you're using your palm on
the screen it will actually not register
as I'm kind of drawing but the problem
is first you're already getting some
kind of event so in order to make
everything work you're getting first
eight pin goes down or four finger goes
down and then you're moving maybe a
little bit and then you get a cancer
call which is essentially canceling the
entire path which is a signal for you to
remove the entire thing Margaret will
show us now and I see more father thank
you okay let's go over an app that has
really utilized stylus input well and
also implemented some specific stylus
features so first I'm going to go ahead
and put my Chromebook into tablet mode
because it's much easier to write on
okay then I'm going to go ahead and take
out my trusty stylus device and let's
get started okay where does an app that
usually lets me draw and sketch and you
can see here that as I put my palm
across the screen there are no marks
from it at the same time I can write
with my palm on the screen and there are
no marks from that from my palm this is
because the system is detecting the palm
in aborting the event path and in the
app picks that up in undoes the line
that has been drawn so far from my palm
so one thing foot has also done is
they've implemented a pressure
sensitivity feature which you can see
here so what that does is that allows me
to make lighter or darker lines based
off of how hard I press on the screen
this means that lighter lines are from
lighter pressure and darker lines are
from darker or heavier pressure so with
that I'm going to send you back over to
Stephane to wrap up input Thank You
Margaret
next thing is input compatibility mode
so the thing with the compatibility is
well very simple
no one was accusing Mouse yet right so
therefore the scroll wheel has a special
input it is defined by Android since
ever but no one is using it on the
Chromebook this is of course pretty bad
because if you're using then for example
your mouse nothing will move when you're
trying to scroll in order to solve this
we have a compatibility mode so and what
we do is we look at that thing we have
the event and we are converting it
automatically in a touch touch scroll
event and that is usually done under the
hood for you if you don't care about
this kind of thing everything will
simply work however if you do care about
these kind of things and other special
input wheels you can actually specify in
the user section of your manifest file
Android hardware type key C if you do
that and please uses false because
otherwise you run only on Chromebooks
then you will get the full breadth of
all the different input events possible
and yeah since we are running a little
bit short I try to speak the SS which as
so that means like you're actually
getting them the proper scroll event and
you can also then check out the you can
distinguish the two thing of touchpad
scrolling from the touchscreen scrolling
by looking at get sauce and you can
distinguish also the direct operations
the drag-and-drop operation from the
touchpad scroll action so this brings me
now to the last program how to test your
application to ensure a positive user
experience so first off you should
definitely make sure that all your
manifest files are in order so which
means like check out that you are
specifying the orientation you want to
use the size you want to use at the meta
flex if you want to use them and check
out the de minimis max width and all
these kind of things they are actually
specified properly if you are interested
in the special event use Android
hardware type pcs which will definitely
give you all the events then you should
definitely test the resizing of your
window so make it really long try to
resize your window as crazy as possible
use or developer option and make sure
that everything is smooth and it's not
crashing and then also change the device
from tablet into into notebook form
factor to see that everything is working
fine and also make sure that that's a
caption so the window control bar is not
offsetting your input events by some
kind of fraction of the screen so and
make sure that the save and restore is
working properly that you are restoring
that properly and that everything works
there as well yeah very soon we will
have an emulator for you you should
actually take out your phone you should
actually make a screenshot of this thing
because nobody can remember the very
exciting shortcuts goog l /q h PT k z if
you want to sign up for our VIP machine
you can actually do it there and we will
actually send you then a preview as soon
as it's ready which should be fairly
soon
so with that you should actually be able
to develop everything locally without
need without the need of using a Chrome
if you are if you have any more specific
questions then please go to our
developer site on
developer.android.com/design ow but we
will add more stuff to it over time so
with that let's summarize and wrap up
the session I'm doing that now very fast
so the takeaway is the application is
already working everything is fine you
don't you shouldn't really worry well
maybe you should worry you should
definitely try it out you should
definitely move to API level 24 unless
you want to be stuck into a small window
plan for huge screen very very important
allow your application to be resizable
make sure to specify window requirements
on your manifest file as mentioned
earlier be consistent with the window
orientation and add all the nice desktop
features which are making a desktop a
desktop
[Music]